ihr glück schien perfekt auf diesen
familie foto was wir ihnen jetzt gleich
zeigen wollen lächelt die familie noch
in die kamera auf diesem foto sieht man
den vater steffen die neugeborene nora
sohn finn und mutter sarah doch jetzt
ist die halbe familie ausgelöscht durch
einen crash mit einem jaguar verliert
steffen seine frau und seinen
einjährigen sohn mutter sarah war mit
ihrem kind genannt in nohra und einer
freundin in ihrem auto unterwegs als es
zu diesem tragischen unfall kommt sarah
die freundin nadine und der kleine finn
waren sofort tot wie nora überlebte wie
durch ein wunder leicht verletzt nora
ist alles was mir bleibt sagte vater
steffen k zu bild und jetzt ist mehr
janine wollbrett bild reporterin live
zugeschaltet sie steht für uns an der
unfallstelle hallo jenny ja hallo was
kannst du uns jetzt über den
unfallablauf genau sagen ja das steht
hier direkt am unfallort wir sind ja auf
der k 1 diese jaguar fahrer kam hier von
dieser strecke von weisenheim am sand um
die kurve man sieht es ist eine
kerzengerade strecke bis zu diesen
gelben striche auf der fahrbahn wo man
dann die da kam es zum zusammenprall mit
mitsubishi fahrerin der mutter der
aufprall war so heftig dass die mutter
ins zehn meter weiter weitere feld
katapultiert wurde in den wingert
geknallt ist und erhält so ein kaputtes
auto haben sie noch nie gesehen wie
mussten die leichen regelrecht
aus rauer herausschneiden und also
sollen sie plötzlich alt gewesen sein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren